and if the king is going to be replaced
it will be a replacement from jordan
love the quarterback that the packers
acquired by trading up from number 30 to
number 26 in the 2020 draft here are
both devante adams and matt lafleur
answering questions and talking about
jordan love as he he's the beneficiary
here he shows up at mandatory mini camp
as qb one here's adam's on the floor
what areas have you seen jordan grow in
since the last time that you saw him
face to face
i can't i truly can't answer that i mean
i can't talk about growth over the
course of you know a hour and a half
practice it's really tough and that's
not i hope that doesn't come off um you
know snippy at all i'm just saying it's
it's a tough position to to really feel
good about your growth obviously
the maturity and i think the mindset is
very locked in and i've noticed that um
but in terms of throwing the ball i mean
we get a few reps of team team cracks
every day you know i'll be able to tell
over the course of maybe three days a
little bit better than one but
um you know even then it's gonna take
much more time probably through camp
i'll be able to give a better assessment
of where he's at um you know or just be
able to just for myself to know honestly
so um i see like like i said i'll say
this he's he's tapped into it
i see his he's a heightened awareness
and his focus is definitely off the
charts right now i can tell the way he's
coming in talking everybody um you know
i hear more last year i felt like it
kind of just blended in this year i'm
starting to feel him and uh you know
it's good that he's starting to step
into his own get more comfortable
um you know i'm sure a lot of it had to
do with not wanting to step on 12 toes
he needs every rep he can get right now
he's a young quarterback that was not
afforded a preseason last year and so
give him as many as he can handle and
we'll
you know spell him every now and again
but i just think every rep that he takes
is so valuable and you can learn
something from
both the good and the bad
i i
had previously said matt lafleur is the
one who is blameless in all of this even
more blameless if that's possible
in this is jordan love
yeah and let's let's have that
conversation right
you come out of college yeah highly
regarded right end up being a
first-round pick and this gets back to
my
anti-draft crusade oh yes it does do you
really think jordan love would have
picked the green bay packers do you
really think of course if he had the
choice of which team to go to that he
would walk into this mess and now
because aaron isn't there he's the guy
he's the guy and he's acting like the
guy and he's asserting himself hey i'm
i'm i'm the guy i'm the guy and then if
aaron rodgers shows up for training camp
he goes back to being not the guy again
and he's he's getting jerked around by
the circumstances that he didn't create
i feel bad for jordan yeah i hear you i
feel worse for him than i do for matt
laflore uh hmm
you're right it it's it's about equal i
guess i do you're right jordan love a
young kid trying to find his way in the
nfl and he got thrusted into the biggest
you know drama
uh topic we've seen in football over the
last three and four years so you're
right it's not easy it's matt lafleur
knew matt leflore newer should have
known that he was stepping into a
hornet's nest with rogers in the front
office when he took the job he didn't
have to take the job exactly he knew
what he was had to take the job exactly
love had no choice that's right right
and you know and and it is it's a tough
spot it is but at least he's getting his
reps now i do want to hit on
some of the things i just heard from
devonta adams you know
like when he talks about growth it's
only been one practice an hour and a
half all those things i believe him in
that you know i believe him on that
because he probably doesn't even know
where the baseline was of where jordan
love was
at the end of the season or anything
like that they had no experience jordan
love was probably just doing some scout
team reps and that was it he had no idea
of like does he know the offense does he
know the checks and do things like that
let alone the other reason i could tell
you he doesn't know about growth either
is because
like
he would have
i bet you they ran basic plays now
that's the negative about rogers not
being there they're not going to be able
to run their offense the way it was in
the nfc championship game with aaron
rodgers with jordan love the training
wheels are going to be on to a degree so
see there's another reason why he's
probably like i don't really know the
growth because we did basics today we
ran like the basic plays of the offense
right so he's he's got to get a feel for
where the guy is all together that way
too it's young it's raw you know and
that's where rogers being away
you know does hurt the team a little bit
again it's only a three day mini camp
it'd be way more concerning if it was
training camp but yeah they do miss out
on some of the things that would be a
little more detailed you know and and
next level stuff that rogers would be
able to execute in the huddle at the
line of scrimmage that they're not gonna
get with jordan love right now
some of the folks who make their living
covering the packers and therefore don't
want aaron rodgers to ever say don't
waste your time reading that crap have
chimed in with the
assessment of the performance of jordan
love struggling with accuracy 12 and 23
passing in team drills etcetera that's
like sailing past yeah listen that's a
concerning number mike i don't care you
know what it is when you're starting
quarterback 12 for 23 in a practice
anything like that
i mean that's that's not something you
want to see that tells you it's raw
right there and that's continually the
the reports i think we both have heard
over the last year from about jordan
love out of green bay
i don't want to go full-blown conspiracy
mike here and it's impossible to comment
on this without seeing the film of
practice yeah that's right some of the
incompletions were right but
but
i i don't think you're gonna have guys
laying out to catch jordan love passes
in a mandatory mini camp no you're not
you're not you're right you're you're
not going to have
guys that are going to all out and
sacrifice their body and do things like
that and yeah it's not about
you know again yeah maybe they would do
that a little more with rogers because
they're trying to like impress him or do
something like that certainly but you
know again
nonetheless
listen i know
you know some of those guys in the the
local media in green bay you know we we
know them casually here and there and
things like that not i'm not trying to
disrespect and say you know they're not
experts but they've seen enough football
for me to go oh well they know what a
ball means by or inaccurate and
overthrowing people and things like that
to where
it's been a story up there about his
rawness we've heard that and of course
things like this kind of confirm it so
we'll just see where it goes and again i
don't want to judge it you're right you
got to watch the film and know and
things like that but i'm going to say an
nfl starting quarterback in a mandatory
mini camp 23 throws
you know i'm gonna say 25 out of the 32
starters in football are going to go
like 19 to 23 20 for 23 21 at 23. maybe
not all great completions but they're
going to find something to make sure
they executed the offense
simple point though from my perspective
if the receiver cuts off his route five
yards too soon it's gonna look like an
overthrow yeah that's right you're right
we don't know if the mistakes exactly
made by the receiver exactly and the
conspiracy mike portion of this comes
into play
if and when any of the receivers are you
know
not accidentally cutting off their route
five yards early so it ends up being an
overthrow i'm not ready to go there
don't go there yet but these are the
same guys who ultimately are going to be
catching passes from aaron rodgers and
the only reason i'd even have that
thought is because
aaron rodgers surely was pleased with
those tweets
yesterday and pleased with those numbers
it gives him more leverage in this
situation than if rod that if jordan
love had been perfect yesterday i well i
think that's that's part of this whole
power play in my opinion i think you
feel the same way please tell me no if
you don't but i feel like roger's
part of the reason he's doing this
is because he knows jordan loves not
ready and he feels like he's kind of got
them in a tough spot because they don't
want to throw him out there right now
you know you and i heard the reports
that people didn't think he was ready
yet and things like that last year uh so
yeah there was there was plenty of
things and rumors coming out of there to
know that okay wait yeah jordan love
needs to develop and do those things
you know aaron rodgers knew that i'm
sure he assessed the situation a little
bit and then he has that year and i
think that's really part of you know
part of what he's trying to do right now
and why he wants that other year of
security he's probably drawing like oh
do you want to play with jordan love you
serious you really want to do that you
know he's not ready i know he's not
ready you know that is part of it but
the packers aren't blinking on that
aspect of this yet at least uh at least
not now remember aaron rodgers said to
kenny mayne 16 days ago that his mvp
season threw around
the plan i know his belief was without
saying it he didn't say it but if if he
thinks he's throwing a wrench in their
plan by being the mvp then the plan was
we're going for aaron rodgers jordan
love after one year yeah right and the
other side of that plan is this guy's
not ready good luck go ahead exactly so
the guy who was the mvps out you're
thrust
into a situation where jordan love is
going to be the starter and he's not
ready
and who's it going to make look bad it's
going to make brian gooda koontz look
bad the guy that rogers reportedly wants
to have fired with that you know when i
think of it that way
i i land at the
maybe he's not showing up maybe this is
his ultimate revenge even though it's
gonna cost him more than 30 million
dollars between lost salary and bonus
payback because if he doesn't show up
and they have to go with jordan love and
jordan love
as you would say pees down his leg all
year long and isn't ready and they go
four and thirteen
then good koontz looks like the [ __ ]
yeah and it's advantage aaron rodgers
yeah i mean i i got to think that's part
of rogers you know plan ultimately but
you know green bay is gonna continue to
to sit in the corner of we don't think
you'll really sit out and miss one of
the last few years of your career and
all those things so rogers is trying to
make them squirm by going uh if i come
you're stuck with that guy but green bay
sitting there going do you really want
to give up one of your last few years of
your prime and really like do that and
we're a good football team and i think
ultimately that's where rogers will come
back uh
and so we'll see if jordan love can can
get better and develop and i'm i'm
really like i would say out of like all
the draft picks
from last year this year new players in
the nfl whatever
jordan love pre-season football this
year is going to mean must-watch tv
because of this situation now and it's
going to be one of those there's like oh
green bass playing oh the second team's
in let me turn on the tv i want to watch
jordan love the first team right or the
first team exactly so we'll see where it
goes
there's a story at pft i'm not going to
get into the details now chris and i
have talked about this a couple of times
but i thought it through yesterday i did
a little research
this isn't really a crusade it's
gratuitous that's gratuitous in about 20
minutes late um
if rogers is not going to show up this
year it makes a lot more sense for him
to retire before camp retire before camp
you avoid the 50 000 per day fine
and you can actually come back
at a point later in the season than if
you don't show up and are put on the did
not report list up so
and and if he retires people will lose
their minds because the casual fan
doesn't understand how easy it is to
unretire even after we've seen multiple
examples of it but
retirement is is a smarter play for him
but at the tune of about two million
dollars and being able to show up out of
the blue a couple of weeks later if he
goes that route so we'll see how it all
plays out it begins with training camp
we assume he's not going to roll into
lambeau field either the next two days
now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports